mario draghi presidents at the European
Central Bank met with mep s to take
stock of the eurozone's monetary policy
among the topics in the spotlight
quantitive easing a program in which
central banks in the eurozone buy
government bonds on the market we
believe that the recovery in inflation
in our projections as I mentioned it's
going to be 0 this year 1.5 the next
year 1.7 the year after by 2016 more
than one thousand one hundred and forty
billion euros are set to be injected
into the economy Mario Longhi de Turini
itz totally flexibility as a disposition
male-to-male send a pic Toronto app
Wittek monitor at mobile easy and no
Papa Ferris all to Hawaii if you don't
reform the European economies but power
enormous amounts of rather cheap money
with very little interest rates then
you're risking getting a rise in asset
values in other words creating
speculative bubbles on the market the
ECB is looking to purchase sovereign
debts amounting to 60 billion euros each
month